I didn't go into this to prove anything
to anybody other than myself
you know there was a lot of raised
eyebrows although that could raise their
eyebrows when you know when when they'd
heard I was going to do this you know a
pop star who's married to a football are
really going to do a clothing line when
someone kicks me you know I try hard to
get up again she's an English
entrepreneur a fashion designer model
and singer she rose to fame with the
all-female pop group bikes girl in the
past decade she's become an
internationally recognized fashion icon
and designer she's Victoria Beckham and
here's my take on her top ten rules for
success remember what is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which ones
you guys like the best also as she's
talking if she said something that
really impacts you please leave it in
comments below and put quotes around it
so that other people can be inspired as
well enjoy
[Music]
it is what I always want you to do no
fashion really is my passion it's what I
what I love to do it's what I have to do
I love what I do I don't consider what I
do is my job I always say well it's it's
almost like it always feels like a hobby
that has done really really well because
I love it you know and a lot of people
don't associate work with enjoying
themselves and they don't associate work
with being their passion whereas I
really do the fashion was always my my
passion and I'm living a dream I really
am and I wake up every morning and I
pinch myself I'm very very lucky I feel
very blessed so I would say right now is
definitely where I feel comfortable I
believe that I'm competing in an arena
where actually I I feel like kind of
good I feel kind of good at this I've
got a long way to go there's lots of
things that I want to do I was never
going to be the best singer or the best
answer and that okay I had four other
people with me she quite well I did that
I can't be bad but you know I would I
kind of hid behind the others a little
bit but you know I really feel that I
have something to give I feel that I
have a point of view and I have I had a
lot to say and and it's great when you
find something that you're that you
think that you're okay Act I say the
best advice that I could give anybody is
to work for somebody else work for
another brand and when I was working
with rock and Republic when I was
working with Linda foe which is a
sunglasses brand that I was working for
I would like a sponge and you can take
that opportunity to learn so much about
the industry and I did that they were
licensed deals that I had back in the
day and I worked with Coty the fragrance
company the fragrance house as well and
I learned so much and then when I was in
a position to bring everything in-house
and own everything myself and create a
team that would do this with me I felt
ready
do it so though I didn't really I didn't
go to fashion school I was working for
other people and I learned an enormous
amount of times an enormous amount in a
very short space of time I always want
to better myself I don't consider myself
I don't throw out and consider other
designers competition you know for me my
competition is me from the season before
I'm very ambitious I always want to
better myself I never sit back and say
wow look at what I've achieved and to be
honest I kind of wish that I could do
that because I should do that but I
always just want to better myself and
what's next and how can I improve how
can I make myself better I am a
perfectionist but in the nicest sense of
the word I was going to say that you
know I didn't know a lot of celebrities
that have a lot of clothing lines or
perfumes and I think that's where what
I'm doing is very different I'm not just
putting my name on different products
you know I'm very involved I'd go to the
factories I see the denim you know I I
work with the people that I'm working
with
and I think that's what make what I'm
doing very very different I'm creative
director I've been working on everything
you know that I'm working on now for the
last seven years this has been a long
long process and that's how long it
taken to get it right I'm not just
saying I'm Victoria Beckham I'm going to
put my name on a bottle of perfume I'm
actually creating that I'm designing the
bottle you know I'm designing the label
and that's what I love that's my fourth
child when I initially started up the
brand I didn't put too much pressure on
myself I didn't go into this to prove
anything to anybody other than myself I
was very focused I didn't try and do
everything at once
you know first for quite a few seasons I
start to just perfecting the dress I
didn't to run before I could walk
it's very important to be focused and do
and do what I was doing very very well
and move on and do more when my team was
in the position to do that so I think
that it's about keeping things focused
and I'm not going to do too much do you
care what people say what people think
oh now I mean I gave up a long long time
worrying and concerning myself over that
you know I care what people say about
what I do professionally I care about
what my customer says you know that
that's what I do care about because why
do I do what I do I do what I do because
I love women I want to empower women I
want women to feel good I want them to
feel beautiful and so I care about what
what my customer thinks because I want
to give her what she wants but generally
speaking I don't I don't focus too much
on anything negative when I first
started so ten seasons ago I had a room
actually at a hotel in in New York and
ideas sometimes one-on-one presentation
sometimes as a group of people sometimes
it was one-on-one and I did that for
four days to fashion press buyers and I
literally would talk through the
collection I had ten dresses and I'd sit
there and I'd talk about the dress and
the dress would come in on a model and I
done picked the dress and talked about
the corset tree and the inspiration and
the fabrics sometimes I'd be talking for
hours and then to people that didn't
that feeling speak English so they were
foreign retailers but I just like to
talk so I'd be talking away and really
wanted people to understand the concept
really and understand what I was doing
and I remember it was 3 o'clock in the
morning the night before the show and I
was standing in there was a florist
actually in the hotel and I was standing
there in my slippers trying to decide on
the flowers you know I didn't have a
stylist or great hair and makeup things
have come such a long way since those
days but I think right at the beginning
I didn't know what people were going to
think you know there was a lot of raised
eyebrows although it could raise their
eyebrows where you know when
when they heard I was going to do this
you know a pop star who's married to a
football are really going to do a
clothing line you know a lot of people
had preconceptions and I didn't go out
to prove anybody wrong I just wanted to
prove to myself like to do it and what
comes to with your determination at all
cost to actually succeed I mean is that
a sort of a message that you hope it
comes across to two kids because a lot
of kids think that people just become
famous overnight darling yeah I think
that people don't realize that it's all
about hard work I mean I worked hard
when when I was at school I've always
had it in my personality to want to
succeed you know even when it was you
know I want to do my homework right but
yeah I mean I'm one of these people you
know when someone kicks me you know I
try hard to get up again because I know
what I want to do I love what I do at
the end of the day I know that I'm
putting myself up for criticism I'm very
much aware that but I love what I do
only everybody has crazy moments of
self-doubt and I think that an element
of that is it's probably quite important
and it's about creative visualization
and challenging yourself but always
staying by positive there's nothing
wrong with having a second little person
you know and sitting on your shoulder
you know making sure that you are
remaining humble and that your being or
your remaining appreciative of
everything that you have and everything
that you've achieved but you should
definitely not wait too much time being
negative in any way it's about positive
thinking positive energy and and
fighting if you need to fight and I mean
my team is so great we're it were small
team but we're growing and they're all
incredibly talented passionate focused I
also think it's important to enjoy the
people that you're working with as well
we have a lot of fun every day but
they're passionate they love what they
do they believe in my brand and what I'm
18 and I had the same team that I had
when I first started over six years ago
and I really encourage my team to grow
with me as I grow as a brand as well yet
by bringing in a few new people but it's
about giving and people that work with
me the opportunity to grow within the
company as well I have a few people that
started out with me as interns that now
have you know high up jobs in marketing
press and sales as well so it's a really
nice family atmosphere at work thank you
guys so much for watching I made this
video because Chris Dunlop asked me to
so there's a favorite entrepreneur that
you are made of profile necks leave it
down the comments below and I'll see
what I can do I'd also love to know what
did you learn from Victoria in this
video what's the thing that you're going
to apply immediately to your life or
your business after watching this clip
super curious to find out leave in the
comments I'm going to join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to Sandra from Kitsch cakes
Sandra thank you so much for picking up
a cup of my book your one word and
making those awesome tributes cookies
they looked amazing and they taste it
even better and I really really really
appreciate your support
tah-dah this is what we've me for you in
tribute to your hashtag believe here we
go
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love please